These people are actually demonic. They're actually satanic.
They actually genuinely are evil. They want pain and violence
and destruction for
This is putrid, wretched, repulsive. >> Whenever you support
literal
terrorists,
then it's going to be different. >> are demons. They're
evil. They They covet death. >> I think this is a great
bit of evidence that you need to completely crush these
This is going to be about should liberals defend Hasan
[__]
Should liberals defend Hasan [__] What should they
say about Hasan [__] And to start this off, we're
going to watch a Kyle Kulinski video from 2 days ago. All right,
this is about should Hasan [__] be in jail? >> So,
the fascist terrorist imperialist bloodthirsty death cult of
MAGA and the Trump regime uh they are now openly targeting political
opponents in the most disgusting way imaginable. So, look at
this. Federal officials have allegedly subpoenaed Hasan [__]
and Code Pink's Medea Benjamin over aid mission to Cuba. The
Treasury Department has targeted the pair as part of an investigation
into whether activists violated US sanctions in delivering medicine
and medical equipment to Cuba. So, here's one of the problems
with this. They didn't actually violate sanctions. In fact, they
go out of their way and they bend over backwards to make sure
they're abiding uh by all of the rules, all the laws, all the
regulations. Um in fact, as Hasan himself pointed out, um this
appears to be the case that Fox News or the Trump regime or both
fell for a viral post that claimed that Hasan was staying at
a hotel, which is not on the US government approved list, which
means he's, you know, economically
the regime in Cuba and therefore it's a crime and >> We
covered that on stream. You guys remember that? When people were
like looking up his blinds and stuff to figure out when all of
Twitter for a quick millisecond decided to do the Kiwi Farms
thing and start looking up the style of blinds at all of the
hotels in Cuba? You guys remember that? I remember that. That
was a good time. >> And therefore he can be charged. There
was some viral right-wing slop post that claimed that. Uh meanwhile,
it's totally untrue, completely and utterly made up. Um they
followed the rules, followed the regulations, went to the approved
list of hotels, went >> I like the energy, but Kyle, there's
no way to truly know that. Um I agree with you. I agree nobody
knows for sure like what hotel he was staying at. Like realistically,
there could just be people lying.
it's whatever. As far as I know, Code Pink is pretty dubious.
And And?
Wait, if the Taliban wanted to donate aid to people who were
like starving, would you go, "No, no, no, no, no, no, the Taliban's
[__] up." Or would you go, "Well, I guess uh sometimes
bad groups do good things for maybe possibly nefarious reasons."
But like it's going to help people, so it's okay.
That's how I look at it. It's like you can tell me Code Pink
is directly funded by China, and I still wouldn't care. >> You
know, down the path that they're supposed to go down. Meanwhile,
there is somebody who actually did uh violate US law in going
to Cuba and staying at one of the incorrect hotels. The kid's
name is Nick Shirley. Yes, Nick Shirley was just in Cuba making
some propaganda documentary in that, and he violated the rules
and the regulations and the laws. But of course, the chances
of the Trump regime going after Nick Shirley are roughly 0%,
and the chance of them going after Hassan is of course very,
very high. Now, by the way, I said allegedly subpoenaed because
Hassan has actually not been served a subpoena yet, neither has
uh Code Pinker Medea Benjamin. None of them have actually been
served subpoenas, so there's some speculation that maybe this
is Fox News taking a viral post and running with it uh without
actually having sources within the Trump regime, within the government.
However, I do fear, even if that is the I do fear you'll immediately
see the Trump regime sort of jump on this and try to bring it
to fruition. Because here's the thing, guys, they don't get they
might even know, "Oh, this is going to go absolutely nowhere."
>> and an arc humiliation. But that's not the point, it
doesn't matter. As long as they they it's not really about Hassan,
it's not really about Code Pink or Medea Benjamin. It's about
everybody else who's thinking of bucking the regime. Everybody
else who's thinking about helping one of these countries which
we are terrorizing and destroying and starving to death. That's
the point. It's to strike fear into people in the same way they
went after James Comey multiple different ways. Every single
way failed instantly, fell apart. But the point is the headlines.
The point is you know the the fear that you put in MAGA critics,
MAGA dissidents. Like hey, shut the [__] up. Hey,
don't criticize us too much. Hey, maybe we'll muck up some charges
against you. And of course the irony of all of this is Trump
never shut the [__] up about the political persecution
of Biden and the Democrats going after me and all the January
6th and it's like no you idiot, they went after you because you're
actually a criminal. You're charged with 91 crimes. You're 34-time
convicted felon. You actually committed multiple crimes. But
you found liable in a civil court for a tax fraud and insurance
fraud and >> Code Pink got an email from the office of
what is this? Often a office of foreign something.
They've not been served a subpoena. Medea Benjamin tells me Code
Pink now has gotten an email from the office of foreign assets
control. That's what it is. Office of foreign assets control
requesting information about the trip. Not a subpoena, but does
confirm some sort of probe. Okay.
Honestly, I don't necessarily hate the idea of there being a
probe so long as it's not being taken to like a legal like a
legal extent immediately. Like people did go on a trip to Cuba.
There were a lot of there was a lot of chatter about them staying
at unsanctioned
Like if they just say, "Hey, could you just show us your like
receipts so we could put this to rest?" That's probably not actually
government corruption,
Now, if you're a total [__] psycho and cheering on
the idea that Hassan might be subpoenaed and might go to then
that's a problem. But like it is if they're literally just reaching
out and going like, "Hey, just let us put this to bed. Like just
send us your your receipts or whatever and we'll be fine." >> It's
actually upholding a lot of go after you idiots. And if Biden's
Justice Department if it was so biased and they were politically
persecuting everybody, why is it they went after Bob Menendez?
Why is it they let charges go against Hunter Biden? Why is it
they went after multiple Democrats? It turns out there was no
political persecution. Except you guys, you're the ones doing
the political persecution. I wouldn't want to be like >> This
is all true, by the way. The Trump administration is doing political
persecution, even if they're not doing it against Hasan in this
case, they absolutely are. >> Tish James, I wouldn't want
to be James Comey, I wouldn't want to be
Fani Willis, I wouldn't want to be any of these people who actually
did their job, Jack Smith, and like we're trying to hold Trump
accountable, and now he's like, "Well, I'm going to make your
life a living hell in a mafia boss kind of way just cuz you inconvenienced
me." Like get the [__] out of here. So understand
something, why would they target Hasan [__] Because
Hasan [__] is everything they hate and everything
they can't control and everything they're scared of. Hasan [__]
he's out there fighting for Medicare for all. He's out there
fighting for free college. He's out there fighting for living
wage. He's out there fighting against Israel.
Okay, he's out there fighting against the Epstein class who controls
the Trump
And they can't have that. Why would they target Hasan [__]
Because Hasan [__] is everything they hate and everything
they can't control and everything they're scared of. Hasan [__]
he's out there fighting for Medicare for all. He's out there
fighting for free college. He's out there fighting for living
wage. He's out there fighting against Israel.
Okay, he's out there fighting against the Epstein class who controls
the Trump
And they can't have that. Especially since now he's getting national
prominence. Especially since now he's endorsing Democratic candidates,
and when he does that, those Democratic candidates are going
up 10 points, like Abdul El-Sayed. Right? So if anything, this
is going to backfire. This is going to make Hasan a bigger figure.
He becomes a national figure. He becomes more known. He becomes
more loved by the Democratic voting base. Cuz the Democratic
voters already love Hasan for what he stands for if they know
him, right? They know him as the tax the rich guy. They know
him as the universal healthcare guy. They know him as the anti-genocide
guy. Now, he's also being persecuted by the fat
con man president. War criminal, like Now all of them are going
to go, "Oh, well, I'm definitely on this guy's side." Again,
Medea Benjamin, same thing. We love Medea Benjamin. We love Code
Pink. Exact same thing. This just makes them more prominent,
more well-known. If you wanted to find a way to get normie Democrats
to support Hassan, you couldn't have come up with a better plan.
Normie Democratic voters now will love this man. Now this man
could run for a high office and win. That's what you need to
understand.
So, massive massive miscalculation. Like I said, it is possible
that Fox News
fell into a you know, fell for a viral tweet that's a lie and
ran with this and there wasn't plans to go after Hassan, but
my guess is that now now the fact that they actually did that,
you will see the Trump regime try to scramble to catch up to
do something like this. But of course there's there's zero case.
There's zero case. By the way, stop and think about this. They've
not arrested any Epstein
but they're arresting Hassan or theoretically going to investigate
Hassan and subpoena Hassan and and Medea Benjamin for the crime
of serving ramen noodles to hungry people. For the crime of delivering
diapers and medical supplies and food to people who need the
help because our country is illegally embargoing them and starving
them and trying to collapse the country.
I mean, what a sick joke. So, humanitarianism is a crime, but
children is not according to these demons. According to these
disgusting
I'm so sick of them, bro. I am so sick of these criminals and
these terrorists. We're being run by like Not only do we not
live in a meritocracy, we live in an anti-meritocracy. We're
being run by the worst people on Earth. These people are actually
demonic. They're actually satanic. They actually genuinely are
evil and they want they want pain and violence AND DESTRUCTION
>> DUDE, I'M HEARING IT. I'M hearing
I'm hearing Vaush breaking through right now with the Kyle rhetoric.
These people are demons. They're evil. They they covet death.
Dude, it's awesome. I I the the Vaush rhetoric breaking through,
okay? >> For those who even 1% disagree with them, there's
not a there's not a a a decent bone in any of these people's
bodies, okay? But, I'm not done because we also have this. Look
at this. Nick Fuentes says, "If Trump wants to win us back, putting
Hasan [__] in prison forever would be a good start."
14,000 Groper likes, ladies and gentlemen. Laura Loomer, uh the
woman who allegedly sucks off the president and controls her
like modern-day Rasputin. "President Trump can unite the entire
country by having Hasan [__] arrested. It's his destiny."
Wow. Also, is that a little play on words I see there? Because
a little guy by the name of Destiny, and I do mean little, a
little guy by the name of Destiny also
What? Oh, what?
>> is excited about this and thinks it's awesome. This
is putrid, wretched, repulsive, dis- >> He's just a little
He's just a little guy. He's just a little guy. He's just a little
guy.
He's just a little tiny guy. Disgusting
>> None of these people believe in anything. None of them
believe in anything. Like I said, at the core, they're they're
an empty black void of morality and intelligence, and it's just
I don't like this person cuz they have more clout than me, so
I hope their life is ruined, and I hope the government
you know, destroys them. Like, what a sick joke, man. >> 100%
yes. >> What about that other guy? What's his name? 2 Raw
2 Real or whatever. He's a was a big communist stan, and he's
out there basically cheering on Trump. Yes, you heard me correctly.
Cheering on
Uh and saying like >> Dude, the best part of this is Okay,
I'll open that tweet Austin just sent. It's like, dude, you understand
this is like the prevailing opinion, right?
This is like the prevailing opinion amongst all of these people.
Do you not understand that going after this guy is really stupid
for you? I have no sympathy for Hasan, either, but Destiny should
be in jail, as well, alongside Hasan. Dude, like, WHY ARE YOU
APPEALING TO THESE PEOPLE? Why are you like leaning into this?
It doesn't make any
All of these people No, these are the Asmongold fans. They see
no difference between Hasan and Destiny. They think they're basically
the same.
I'm telling you they think they're basically the same. I don't
know why Why would you lean into this? It's so
There's another point here. Real quick, real quick, real quick.
>> Is that a little play on words I see there? Because
a little guy by the name of Destiny, and I do mean little, a
little guy by the name of Destiny also is excited about this.
Every single person
Actually,
has Hasan ever called me short before? Oh, whoops. I'm sure he
had. I I don't know if he had. I feel like every person, every
man on the internet that has called me short has been my height
or shorter in real life.
That's I feel like that has happened with almost every single
person. So, he actually Kyle is shorter than Chris. Is Ninja
short? Is Ninja real short?
Is Ninja tiny?
He's tall, isn't he? In their marriage photos? Well, I tower
over you, but Good one. He's wrong on Kyle's height. Kyle is
taller than him. How am I 5'8"?
Hold on, let's check. Kyle Kulinski
6'5" Oh, no shot. Hey, no. 5'
8" 5'
Is she like 5'10" or something? Is she Wait, is Destiny Is Destiny
shorter than Crystal Ball? Destiny thinks the height difference
between these two people is 2 in by the way. Destiny looks at
this and he goes, "Yeah, it's about 2 in." Yeah, it's about 2
in right there. For ultra tall?
Him near Joe Rogan
It looks so insecure to cope about this.
It's It's so insecure to cope about this, bro.
Joe Rogan should Are you good? Joe Rogan like 5'6", right?
guy by the name of Destiny, and I do mean little, a little guy
by the name of Destiny also is excited about this and thinks
it's awesome. This is putrid, wretched, repulsive, disgusting
None of these people believe in >> Shut the [__]
up, you loser. >> I You know what? I take that back. If
Kyle Kulinski has a video of him calling out Hasan for cheering
on Adam Schiff or any of the other people who have been threatened
by this administration on the left, then you know what? Then
He probably thinks it's a joke. Then Kyle has a leg to stand
on. Other You You can't say it's a joke. Just like whenever you
do something wrong, Destiny can never go, "Oh, I was just kidding."
Because if he tries to go, "Oh, I'm just kidding." Unfortunately,
there's a record of him doubling, tripling, quadrupling down,
right? Like in this moment where he is doubling down, tripling
down, "No, Hasan should be arrested. No, [__] Hasan."
In this moment, he's doubling, tripling, quadrupling down.
And we can all see how fake he is, how he doesn't hold any any
kind of principle at all. Even though some of these people, when
Destiny got targeted or even was perceived to be targeted, they
stood up for him. Cuz they understand there's no difference to
the MAGA regime between Destiny and Kyle Kulinski. There's no
difference to those guys.
>> Should sit down and shut the [__] up, you
virtue-signaling little [__] Get the [__]
out of here. >> He's He's calling people little now. It's
so try Dude,
so insecure. When you take someone else's insult, it means it
landed.
You You take He gets called short by Kyle Kulinski, and immediately
he tries to throw that back at Kyle Kulinski.
That means the insult landed for you. Right? You think that's
a good insult. So, you throw that insult back. When I call Destiny
little, by the way, I don't mean in stature, although that is
obvious. I always mean like in terms of his ego, in terms of
his like self-confidence, he is a little person. He is a tiny
little man. Right? I don't mean literally, although that would
also be true. I mean in terms of like
oh, his self-confidence.
In terms of
I don't know, his grandiosity as a person. There's just nothing
there. He's insubstantial. He's very small.
That was it for that. We We have to keep on with Kyle video.
We're going to keep going with the Kyle video. >> Hasan
voted for Kamala. You didn't break out your pom-poms strongly
enough and cheer for her. Therefore, you deserve this. Are you
kidding me? Are you kidding me? The pettiness, the vindictiveness,
the how embarrassing. And you you people want to lead a movement?
That's what you want to do? You want to lead a movement? You
want to bring us out of this fascist hellscape that we're in?
Uh uh like the opposite of leaders. These people are deeply,
deeply unserious.
Again, the fact of the matter is he's being targeted for being
a decent person. He's being targeted for being a left-winger.
This is Somebody said This is quite literally the poem of like
first they came for the communists, right? Like this That's That's
what it this is. First they came for the socialists. That's what
this is. And you're going to sit there and cheer it on? Well,
guess what? You're on that list. They make no distinction
between you and him. Do you not understand that? Destiny, too
raw, too real. Any And And by the way, let me be clear. There's
no like no democratic voters are cheering this on. It's only
>> Exactly. Exactly. There's no distinction for these people.
Why the [__] are you cheering cuz somebody just like
That's the whole Man. That's the whole point of having a principle,
dog. That's the whole point. Is that even if you hate somebody,
you should stand on your principles, or else they will wither
away and rot.
Obviously, man. >> weird media pundit freaks who are way
too online. They make no distinction. You and Hasan are exactly
the same. To them. They view Oh, there's no difference between
you guys. You're all left of center. Like that's all they need
to know. They throw us all in camps if they could. They're already
DOING THAT WITH ICE. UH God forbid you're you're an immigrant.
God forbid you make a joke about Charlie Kirk. God forbid you're
pro-Palestine. They will lock you up or kick you out of the country.
People have been tortured in in SEECAT. They're building concentration
camps all across this country for the ICE Gestapo thugs, for
Trump's paramilitary. And you're going to sit there and cheer
on when a prominent left-winger gets targeted for doing humanitarianism?
You're going to cheer that on? You're going to support that?
No soul, no soul, no morality, no ethics, no consistency. It
is embarrassing. It is pathetic. Put aside your childish petty
Who gives a [__] about your childish petty internet
beef? Are you serious? This is the real >> I do think like
shockingly Hasan also put it to the side for Destiny. To like
argue on his behalf.
Like actually, for real. Which to me like I do think Destiny's
got it over Hasan about a thousand times more than Hasan's got
back at him. I was shocked that Hasan was willing to put it to
the side to support Destiny when he felt like Destiny might be
targeted, right? >> real world that we're talking about
What a sick joke. Never in a million years will you ever see
me cheer on if the Trump regime goes after you know, a neoliberal
online creator. Never in a million years would I sit there and
cheer that [__] on because I know that they make
no distinction between me and that person, none whatsoever. I
know that it's an injustice, that it's violating their
What a sick joke, man. What a sick joke. So, you know some demonic
[__] is happening when Nick Fuentes and Laura Loomer
both
The one who allegedly sucked Trump off and the one who wants
to suck Trump off.
When the closet case
uh manlet Nazi >> Nick Nick's like slight Nick loves slider
builds. Nick would never get involved with Trump in that way,
okay? Nick would never get involved with Trump in that way. He
likes He likes dudes that are slider build, okay? Come on. Come
on, Kyle. Don't do misinfo.
>> agrees with modern-day uh you know, plastic surgery
Rasputin >> Nick Fuentes would never ever suck the [__]
of a fat man, Kyle. That is slander. That is the height of sir.
You know something's up. You know that you know some horrible
is about to go down. So, you know, as as Hasan always says, judge
him by his
And I think everybody with a functioning brain can do that in
this scenario and
they hate him. They're scared of him. He represents every single
thing that they're not. Uh and they want to make him pay for
that. They want to make him pay for that. They want to make him
pay for daring to support innocent people who are being embargoed
by us and starved by us. That's a crime, but kids on Epstein
Island not a crime. Uh committing
countless instances of fraud on Wall Street not a crime. Trump
pardons fraudsters on a daily basis. Committing immense corruption
on a regular basis
You are such a gay coded straight dude sometimes. Also, you are
correct. Hey, I understand people of all walks of life, okay?
I'm cursed with being the most empathetic No, probably not. I'm
cursed with understanding Nick Fuentes's gayness, okay? That's
I'll say we'll keep it to that. I I just understand how and why
he's gay. Not a crime. Stop and think about this. The same people
who are carpet bombing little girl schools in Iran are saying
Hasan is a criminal for delivering the ramen noodles. I mean,
you can't you can't make this [__] up. You can't
make this [__] up. We live in hell and everybody
needs to be crystal clear on where they stand on this. And if
you're not, sorry, you're not one of the good guys. Now, listen.
Now, Hasan had a reaction to this to the Cenk Uygur video. >> the
one who wants to suck Trump off. >> Yeah, Nick Fuentes
and Laura Loomer agree. So does Asmongold. Asmongold was like,
"Yeah, [__] around and find out.
"Yeah, lock him up." Again,
content creator on this goddamn platform literally supposed to
be
somewhat of a colleague here. Dude, I love that Hasan
Listen, I I Listen, I love Hasan, but I know for a fact that
if I had to like stand shoulder to shoulder if Hasan was in this
drama and he's like the same size creator as like me or or Q
man or or Dickers or Aiden, I feel like Hasan would be out the
door, okay? A little bit. A little bit. I I love Hasan, but he
is like I can feel him wavering even though he knows he's right.
Like I can feel that he is like he's a little spooked.
Do you know what I mean? Like how should I put it? Hasan has
the right positions. Hasan has the right morals. But you could
tell that if he was If he was like a military general, he'd be
like kind of he'd have a little catch in his voice. There's no
iron in this guy. You know what I mean?
Which isn't the worst thing in the But I I can feel that he's
like, "Hasan Gold isn't even supporting me. We're like colleagues.
There has to be a little respect among colleagues." No, man.
No.
You're You're the guy. That's why we need to support him, okay?
We need to be the iron in his in his spine for him, >> all
right? Elevating the prospect >> He stands tall. He can't
stand tall. I'm just laughing that you can tell he's like expecting
his friends to help a little bit. And Hasan Gold's not your friend
anymore, man.
>> It's elevating at the prospect of me uh uh being arrested.
>> Dork is crazy. >> like there's a very easy solution
for this. Bring in the National Guard, round them all up, and
put them in FORCE LABOR >> WHAT? THE ONES who are violent
and attack police, done. You can literally solve this problem
overnight, but we choose to allow these animals to run wild.
Elon Musk 100. >> Do you idiots not understand what anything
like a society, due process, any of that [__]
I mean, it's crazy. Also, what is that [__] Why do
people listen to that guy? He's disgusting. >> And then
Hasan Gold will be like, "Don't call me a fascist. Somebody might
me."
He argues for camps where they round people up and basically
the ones who are violent. Round them all up, put them in force
labor camps. Anybody fights back, whoop. And then it's like,
"Dude, you might be a fascist." Like, "Hey. Hey. WHAT DO YOU
SAY SOMEBODY SHOULD round them all up AND SHOOT THEM?" WHAT THE
[__] ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT? BUT IF YOU CALL THIS
GUY A FASCIST,
apparently that's too far. That's like a bridge too far.
Don't call me a fascist. You want somebody to show up and shoot
me? What the [__] man? Like, I get how say, "But
I'm just saying the violent ones." If your goal is to round them
up and put them in labor camps, isn't that the precise situation
you should get violent in? That's a tyrannical
Isn't that what the Second Amendment is for? I think one more.
I've got an HasanAbi clip. Oh, yes. This is the HasanAbi reaction
today to Kyle Kulinski's clip, the clip from Kyle Kulinski's
video on HasanAbi. >> I get the [__] out of
here. So, I don't understand something. Why would they target
Hasan [__] Because Hasan [__] is everything
they hate and everything they can't control and everything they're
scared of. Hasan >> So, what are you talk Okay. >> [__]
he's out there fighting for Medicare for all. He's out there
fighting for free college. He's out there fighting for a living
wage. He's out there fighting >> out there fighting for
Hamas. That's the problem. Nobody's against Hasan fighting for
Medicare for all. Nobody's against Hasan fighting for, you know,
more livable wages. Nobody >> Does Hasan bring Hamas up
when he goes to do his streams? >> was ever against that.
>> Did that really happen? >> Everybody said, "You
know what? We might not agree with you, but that's not it. Whenever
you support literal
then it's going to be different. I don't know why these people
try to
>> And And this is this is the problem that a lot of these
leftist people have is that they are inside of this cult of just
constantly and intentionally
misunderstanding
every single criticism against them and then attacking as if
they're being attacked for something that isn't even happening.
Like, they're they're they're they're like addicted Or sorry,
you could say addicted to, but like afraid of being able to acknowledge
any sort of legitimate criticism. >> Hey, he's out there
fighting against the Epstein class who controls the Trump
>> And they can't have that. Especially since now he's
getting national prominence, especially since now he's endorsing
Democratic candidates, and when he does that, those Democratic
candidates are going up 10 points, like Abdul El-Sayed, >> right?
So, if anything, this is going to backfire. This is going to
make Hasan a bigger figure. He becomes more loved by the Democratic
voting base. >> Cuz I think that's not what's going to
happen. I think that that he has too many positions that are
just simply un-American fundamentally.
>> Like what? >> And there are so many really bad
clips, like, you know, for example, saying that it's like better
that like white women get because they're be it's it's like it's
like a harm >> That's not the clip. >> Dude, these
people suck at talking so badly. This is what I'm talking about.
Like, you have to be a total drone to enjoy this. You have to
be a complete droolian to enjoy this.
Like Like, YOU COULD START THAT CLIP. THAT CLIP IS BAD. It It
sounds bad. It probably is bad. But, that's not how you set it
up.
>> reduction or something like that. Like, if you play
that clip, I'm sorry, but like a lot of women are going to say
that's disgusting. Like, you're not going to have women that
are going to say, "Oh, yeah, let let let's go ahead and have
this guy speak for us." The 9/11 clip? Yeah, well, at least the
9/11 clip, you could say that he would Oh, he was talking about
Americans, you know, like it was like a geopolitical thing, right?
He wasn't saying they deserved it personally. The other ones
are way
>> But, grab them by the >> is okay? >> Well,
I think people criticized Trump about that, too. They didn't
like that. I I don't think a lot of people like
>> The Democratic voters already love Hasan for what he
stands for, if they know him, right? They know him as the tax
the rich guy. They know him as the >> As the tax the rich
guy? No, they don't. They know him as the guy that shocked his
dog. That's why when you type in Hasan, the first result is dog.
>> I mean, you could say that, but
is objectively like doing great political work right now.
>> That's what everybody knows him by is by the dog thing.
>> It's literally that simple. Like I mean you can just
look this up immediately and you can just prove this.
>> we're South Korea guy, they know him as the anti-genocide
guy. Now >> The anti-genocide guy? Is that right? >> No,
he's also being persecuted by the
con man president. >> War criminal, like now all of them
are going to go, "Oh, well I'm definitely on this guy's side."
Again, Medea Benjamin, same thing. We love Medea Ben- >> Not
a single correction there at Not a single correction. Yeah, that
all sounds about right. Yeah, that all sounds about right actually.
Yeah, yeah, it
>> Benjamin, we love Code Pink. Exact same thing. This
just makes them more prominent, more well-known. If you wanted
to find a way to get normie Democrats to support his >> And
I think that there is a risk for this. And I think that what
Kyle is saying is partially accurate. I think this is a great
bit of evidence that you need to completely crush these people.
>> Let's go.
Ashton Gold pulling out full full fascism, let's go. We We should
need a We should need everybody. We should say Civil War. Civil
War. Civil War. Ashton Gold Tim Pool arc, let's go. >> You
never take half measures. If they are breaking the law or they're
doing something that's illegal, you have to completely crucify
them. You don't because it You You can't let them be a martyr.
You can't take half measures and then they're able to
>> Does he know what martyr means? Does he know the definition
of martyr?
Does he have any idea what that word means? You You can't let
them be a martyr, so crush them mercilessly.
It's like, wait, do you Wait, do you Are you sure you know what
that word means? As
Are you good? Are you good? Like look at what happened for example
with Trump, right? They
Wait, he did say crucify them. Oh, no.
Can anybody name off the top of my head I can't possibly name
a martyr who was crucified? Wait, guys, is there like a famous
martyr of some kind that has ever been crucified? Has that Crucify
them so that they don't turn into a martyr. This guy's brain
is Man, this guy's brain is broken.